Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Six, Episode Fourteen: school and education in Denmark.
The education system is part of the foundation under Danish society.
First and foremost because education gives citizens knowledge that has value in working life.
One of the most important reasons for a society's economic prosperity and the individual's income is connected with the acquisition of knowledge that can be used on the labour market.
The labour market in a rich country like Denmark therefore to a great extent makes demands on citizens for education and skill.
That applies in relation to basic knowledge such as being able to read and write Danish, do arithmetic, speak English or other foreign languages.
And it applies in relation to more specific knowledge, both practical and academic or theoretical, depending on which education is concerned.
In addition, education is important because it gives citizens common knowledge, identity and the possibility of understanding their everyday life and society.
The history of the Danish education system goes back to the Middle Ages.
In 1479 the University of Copenhagen opened as the country's first.
But oldest are the Latin schools, which arose around 1200 in connection with the cathedrals.
The designation Latin school was kept until 1903 for many of the schools that prepared young people for university.
After the Reformation in the 1500s, children were taught in Martin Luther's Small Catechism, a handbook of the Christian faith.
It was the local priest or sexton, the priest's helper, who taught.
The children often went to school only one or two days a week.
In the 1700s a number of schools were set up.
From the end of the century, teacher training colleges, seminarier, were formed, which had responsibility for educating teachers.
The foundation for the Danish folkeskole came with the school act of 1814, where the rules for teaching were made the same for the whole country.
There is no compulsory school attendance in Denmark, but instead ten years of compulsory education, undervisningspligt.
That means all children must receive teaching for ten years.
Parents can freely choose between the public folkeskole and private schools or teach their child themselves.
There is, however, the requirement that the pupil must reach the same academic level as in the folkeskole, if the child is taught at home or at a private school.
Even though there is no compulsory school attendance, almost 100 percent of Danish children go to school.
The folkeskole comprises a one-year kindergarten class, børnehaveklasse, often called the 0th class, and a nine-year basic course.
There is furthermore the possibility of an extra year in 10th class.
The folkeskole has, according to the Folkeskole Act, the following purposes.
One: the folkeskole must, in cooperation with the parents, give pupils knowledge and skills that prepare them for further education and give them a desire to learn more, make them familiar with Danish culture and history, give them an understanding of other countries and cultures, contribute to their understanding of humankind's interplay with nature and promote the individual pupil's all-round development.
Two: the folkeskole must develop working methods and create frameworks for experience, absorption and the joy of doing, so pupils develop insight and imagination and gain confidence in their own possibilities and a basis for taking a stand and acting.
Three: the folkeskole must prepare pupils for participation, shared responsibility, rights and duties in a society with freedom and democracy.
The school's work must therefore be marked by freedom of mind, equality and democracy.
All subjects are common to girls and boys, and pupils are normally taught class by class and together throughout the school course.
The school cooperates closely with the parents, and parents can get influence on their child's school by becoming a member of the school's board and by taking part in parent meetings at the school.
Pupils have the right to form a pupil council and to elect at least two members to the school's board, where they sit together with parent representatives, representatives of the school's staff and the school's management.
From the 0th class up to the 7th class, pupils do not get grades.
But from the folkeskole's 8th class, pupils get grades in a number of subjects at least two times a year.
The school can in some cases give pupils standpoint grades in the 6th and 7th class together with other feedback.
After the 8th and 9th class, pupils take exams in many subjects.
After the 10th class, pupils can also take exams in many subjects.
The exams can be both oral and written.
The grading scale used in Denmark is called the 7-point scale, the 7-trins-skalaen, because it has a total of seven grades, steps.
There are two grades, minus 3 and 00, for failed performances and five grades for passed performances: 02, 4, 7, 10 and 12.
The highest grade is thus 12, and the lowest grade is minus 3.
The 7-point scale is used everywhere in the Danish education system.
It is voluntary whether you want to continue your education after the ten years of compulsory education.
The labour market in Danish society does however increasingly make demands on citizens for education and skill.
Ten years of schooling is therefore not enough to get most jobs.
All citizens in Denmark have access to many different educations, and by far most educations are free for the individual citizen.
The majority of young people in Denmark continue after primary school with one of the many youth educations, ungdomsuddannelser.
This applies to both sexes.
A youth education can be aimed at the labour market or at further education.
A vocational education, erhvervsuddannelse, can for example be within trade, office or craft.
Within the social and health area you can become a pedagogue's assistant or a social and health care helper.
There are several different upper secondary educations that give access to higher educations, and which include, among others, the general upper secondary school, stx, the business upper secondary school, hhx, the technical upper secondary school, htx, and the higher preparatory examination, HF.
The higher educations vary in length according to what you study.
Higher educations can be short, 2 to 3 years, medium-length, 3 to 4 years, and long, 5 to 6 years.
With a short higher education you can for example become a laboratory technician, computer scientist or building technician.
On the medium-length higher educations you can for example become a pedagogue, journalist, teacher or nurse.
A long higher education can for example be a university education within natural science, health science, social science or humanities.
You must normally have an upper secondary education to be admitted to a long higher education.
If you have a vocational education, there is also the possibility of being admitted to short higher educations and some medium-length higher educations.
There are also many offers of so-called continuing and further education for adult citizens in Denmark.
People often speak of the possibility of lifelong education.
You can educate yourself if you want a new job, within another area than the one you were originally trained in.
Or if, for example, new machines have come to a workplace that require special competences.
Adults have the possibility of taking a vocational education or courses at the vocational schools.
Adults can also take the final exam in individual subjects at folkeskole level or HF at one of the many adult education centres, VUC.
There is furthermore the possibility of taking a supplementary continuing and further education at business academies, university colleges and universities, for example an academy, diploma or master's education, just as there are various educational offers for adults with reading or spelling problems.
More people educate themselves for longer.
In recent decades there has been a marked increase in how long the Danish population is in the education system.
Many more pupils and students have come at the academic educations and far fewer at the practical ones.
In 1982, 36 percent of an age cohort took an upper secondary education.
That has grown to 72 percent in 2023.
Conversely the share of an age cohort that takes a vocational education has fallen from 36 percent to 19 percent in the same period.
Many more also get a long higher education.
About 6,000 students completed a master's degree in 1990, while it was about 10,000 in 2002.
In 2025, about 29,000 students completed a master's degree.
There is broad agreement that it is overall positive that by far most continue their education beyond the compulsory folkeskole.
But the development has led to a number of other discussions about the education system's organisation.
For example, skilled manual labour is lacking, for example cooks, carpenters or electricians, and therefore there has been a discussion of whether too many choose the upper secondary school and too few the vocational schools.
Another challenge is that on some higher educations too many have difficulty finding work when the study is finished.
At the same time too few choose educations such as for example pedagogue and nurse, or technical and natural science subjects such as engineer or computer scientist.
Therefore various measures have been introduced that are to get more students to study the educations that the labour market has the greatest need for.
For example, in 2014 it was decided to introduce the so-called "unemployment-based dimensioning", which puts a ceiling on how many students can be admitted to the educations where there has over a period been high unemployment for newly graduated.
This applies especially to subjects within the humanities and parts of social science such as for example art history, anthropology, philosophy or musicology.
More practice in the folkeskole and the upper secondary school.
Not least as a result of the challenges with the lack of skilled manual labour, education policy in Denmark is undergoing some significant changes in these years.
This is seen both in the folkeskole and at the upper secondary schools.
With regard to the folkeskole, a majority in the Folketing agreed in 2024 that theory and training in practical work are to a greater extent to go hand in hand in the teaching of the folkeskole.
Specifically, all pupils in the larger classes are in future to go on five days of work placement at a workplace.
There is also established a possibility that pupils can go on so-called junior apprenticeship.
That means that pupils in the 8th and 9th class can choose to go to school three days a week, while the last two are spent working and training in a local company.
In addition there are to be more practical elective subjects for the oldest pupils, and understanding of technology is to be part of teaching throughout the folkeskole course.
In 2025 the reforms came to the upper secondary school, where from 2030 a new business- and profession-oriented upper secondary education, epx, is established.
At epx the pupils are to meet a combination of practical and academic teaching.
There must be close cooperation with local companies.
Therefore upper secondary schools which offer epx must have workshops and laboratories where pupils can get practical skills.
At the same time the admission requirements to the general upper secondary school are tightened, which is therefore presumed to get fewer pupils in future.
The reforms also mean that epx gradually replaces HF and the 10th class.
Here is your recap for Episode Fourteen.
The University of Copenhagen opened in 1479 as the first university.
The oldest schools are the Latin schools, from around 1200, with the name kept until 1903.
After the Reformation children were taught Luther's Small Catechism.
The school act of 1814 is the foundation of the folkeskole.
There is no compulsory school attendance but ten years of compulsory education, undervisningspligt.
The folkeskole has a 0th class plus nine years, and an optional 10th class.
No grades until the 8th class.
The 7-point scale has the grades minus 3, 00, 02, 4, 7, 10 and 12; 12 is highest.
Upper secondary educations are stx, hhx, htx and HF.
Higher educations are short, 2 to 3 years, medium, 3 to 4, and long, 5 to 6.
36 percent took an upper secondary education in 1982, 72 percent in 2023; vocational fell from 36 to 19 percent.
About 29,000 completed a master's in 2025; the number completing a long higher education has risen, det er steget.
In 2014 the unemployment-based dimensioning was decided.
In 2024 a majority decided on five days of work placement and junior apprenticeship; from 2030 the new epx is established.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
How has the number of students on the long higher educations developed over the last 20 years?
Option A: It has risen.
Option B: It has fallen.
[DA] Hvordan har antallet af studerende på de lange videregående uddannelser overordnet udviklet sig de seneste 20 år?  A: Det er steget  |  B: Det er faldet
The answer is A: It has risen.
It appeared in the November 2024 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Det er steget
That's the end of this part.
Well done.